as well as this recap video we've got a
new video out now about the first
episode of the expanse season six you
can watch now at the link below
the expanse is a show about space war
family politics alien mysteries and sure
egg dash lou being sassy
goddamn like the sixth and final season
is coming soon so what's happened in the
story so far
in season one humanity is divided into
earth mars and the belt earth is
powerful but it's old and slow its
environment strained by overpopulation
mars is a new rival superpower with
advanced technology unified by the dream
of terraforming mars the asteroid belt
and outer planets are mined for
resources the people of the belt have
their own culture and language and
bodies adapted to space but the belters
are oppressed and exploited by earth and
mars so activists and extremists like
the opa fight for freedom for the belt
in episode 1 a mining ship called the
canterbury is mysteriously destroyed
sparking conflict across the solar
system
four survivors of the attack form an
unlikely crew holden is an idealistic
hero type from earth naomi is a
secretive smart engineer from the belt
alex is a lovable pilot from mars and
amos is
complicated
amos grew up in baltimore as a victim of
organized crime he's emotionally
detached and often violent but he
follows naomi as his moral guiding light
together they steal a ship or rather
they legally acquire a ship by
legitimate salvage and they name it the
rossannante the rossi crew uncover a
conspiracy with the help of a cynical
cop called miller
miller investigates a missing girl
called julie mao it turns out she was
killed by a mysterious alien virus
called the proto-molecule julie's father
a powerful businessman called joe pierre
mao experiments with the virus to make
it a weapon he blew up the canterbury to
deliberately cause war and now to study
the proto-molecule gilpierre infects a
hundred thousand people on the moon of
eros miller and the rosy crew fight to
escape and survive but the
proto-molecule on eros starts building
some weird scary alien [ __ ] so with the
help of opa leader fred johnson the crew
try to knock eros into the sun by
hitting it with a giant mormon spaceship
called the nauvoo but the proto-molecule
makes eros dodge the nauvoo and eros
speeds towards earth so miller journeys
into eros and finds julie mao's
consciousness alive inside the
proto-molecule he convinces julie to
crush eros into venus and they disappear
into the clouds together
so in the face of war and aliens the
rosie crew come together as an unlikely
family and they learn from each other
holden starts out as a dangerously
impulsive naive hero but naomi helps him
to make smarter decisions and eventually
they fall in love
miller challenges holden's moral
idealism and teaches him to be more
ruthless to get stuff done
amos comes to trust holden as a leader
alongside naomi and alex
makes really good lasagna
while the rosie crew flies around saving
the worlds avasarala handles the
politics avasarala is a powerful
politician in the united nations the
government of earth in season one she's
ruthless in protecting earth from
belters and martians she tortures
blackmails lies and betrays because she
believes that earth must come first but
then she discovers that the conspiracy
behind the war didn't come from the belt
or mars people in her own government
conspired with julpier mao to weaponize
the proto-molecule so avasarala fights
the conspiracy with the help of bobby
bobby is a tough martian soldier
fiercely loyal to mars but her squad
gets killed by a proto-molecule monster
and she finds out that the martian
government was behind this they also
work with the juil pierre to weaponize
the proto-molecule they transform
children into proto-molecule killing
machines so bobby defects from mars
suits up and fights to help other
soralla and the rosy crew end the war
they kill some protomolecule monsters
and they help a botanist called prax
save his daughter so these earthers
martians and belters put aside their
differences and work together to make
peace
this story is about the tribal politics
that divide us and the common humanity
that can unite us
but meanwhile on venus alien forces grow
in season 3 the proto-molecule that
crashed into venus rises back up from
the clouds and forms a mysterious ring
like a stargate or wormhole everyone
goes to investigate and among them is
clarissa julpier mao's eldest daughter
clarissa wants to avenge her father's
downfall by destroying holden she gets
high-tech bio-implants that enhance her
speed and strength for short bursts
they're terrible for her health long
term but all clarissa wants now is
revenge so clarissa kills a bunch of
people and frames holden for the crime
the rosie flees through the ring into
the mysterious alien space within holden
gets visions of miller whose
consciousness now exists within the
proto-molecule miller guides him to the
ring station a mysterious structure at
the center of the ring space and holden
learns that the ring and the
protomolecule were created by some
ancient aliens called the builders but
the builders were destroyed by some
other mysterious alien entities
naomi works on the behemoth a giant opa
ship converted from the old mormon ship
the nauvoo the behemoth represents the
dream of a free belter nation naomi's
friend captain drummer clashes with
ashford over their differing views on
governance the ring's security system
suddenly traps everyone in the ring
space many die from a sudden
deceleration of their ships drummer and
ashford work together to survive and
ashford welcomes earthers and martians
to heal on the behemoth a preacher
called anna gives emotional support to
the wounded and she gives a slap in the
face to clarissa for being an
unrepentant murderer
ashford tries to destroy the ringgate
which almost destroys the entire solar
system but holden and the crews stop him
with the help of drummer and bobby and
anna and clarissa who finally lets go of
revenge and helps people instead
after the crisis the ring's true purpose
is revealed inside the ring space new
gates open to a thousand new habitable
solar systems the builders didn't make
the proto-molecule to be a weapon it's a
tool that builds bridges to new worlds
so in season 4 there's a land rush as
people seek new opportunities on new
worlds through the ring on one planet
called illus there's a conflict between
belter settlers and an earth corporation
even with a thousand new worlds
available the inner planets continue to
oppress the belters the rosy crew are
sent to sort it out and holden
investigates alien structures on the
planet which accidentally causes a
catastrophic explosion and tsunami so
everyone hides underground an alien
infection makes them blind people are
killed by death slugs it is no fun but
with the help of a scientist called lv
they shut down the alien tech and the
ghost of miller is finally put to rest
holden defeats the murderous earther
mercury and restores peace lv stays on
illust to study the planet's alien tech
this artifact seems to be connected to
the entities who wiped out the builders
aeons ago
meanwhile on earth avasarala loses most
of her political power in an election
her husband leaves her for being too
ruthless and dishonest politically she
kills civilians in a failed military
strike but alva sarala learns from her
mistakes and she remains committed to
protect all of humanity
in the ring the behemoth becomes medina
station the central hub for the ring
gates drummer and ashford make political
compromises to keep the peace between
the bell to earth and mars drummer hates
compromising on her values as a belter
so she quits to become a polyamorous
space pirate instead but then ashford is
killed by belter extremist marco inaros
after drummer had let marco go free so
drama feels guilty for ashford's death
on mars bobby is depressed because the
martian dream is dying mars used to be
united behind the project to make the
planet a habitable world but now there's
no point in terraforming mars because
there are thousands of already habitable
worlds through the ringgate bobby's
purpose and identity as a martian is
gone so she gets involved in organized
crime and discovers a conspiracy selling
martian stealth tech and ships to marco
inaros marco uses the stealth tech to
paint on some asteroids and launches the
deadly rocks towards earth
because all through the story belters
have been exploited by earth and mars
fred and ashford and doors tried to free
the belt through politics and diplomacy
but they failed even when there were a
thousand new worlds available through
the ring the inner planets still tried
to take them for themselves so marco
argues that belters can only win freedom
through devastating violence against
earth and mars
avasarala discovers marco's stealth
rocks and she tries to save earth but
she's too late the rocks hit earth and
kill millions and with the climate and
ecosystem broken billions more will die
soon other
husband arjun is among the dead this is
avasarala's worst nightmare but she
refuses to kill innocent belters for
revenge avasarala regains power as
leader of earth and works to protect all
people together
amos is on earth when the rocks hit
visiting clarissa mao in jail because
clarissa was imprisoned for her murders
in season 3 but amos makes friends with
her he comes to support and guide
clarissa just like naomi supported him
which goes to show how much amos has
grown
clarissa is in a deep dark place both
literally and emotionally but she and
amos climb their way out and fight to
survive on an apocalyptic earth clarissa
encourages amos to save some innocent
people along the way
amos then brings clarissa to join the
rosie crew despite the fact that
clarissa once tried to kill holden and
many others
cause amos argues that even enemies can
become trusted friends they survive by
growing their tribe
back in the day naomi had a relationship
with marco inaros and they had a son
called philip when marco committed a
terrorist attack naomi left him and
marco kept phillip from seeing naomi
ever since naomi felt grief and guilt of
the separation from her son so now she
finds philip and finally reunites with a
long lost child but philip captures her
and brings her to marco
marco is a selfish narcissistic
emotionally manipulative mass murderer
and naomi begs philip to leave and
escape marco's control but philip
rejects naomi so again naomi is forced
to leave her son behind she jumps
through space to escape suffers on a
booby-trapped ship then jumps into space
again to warn her friends alex and bobby
save naomi but alex dies in the high g
flight alex loved flying and helping his
friends so amos says it's a worthy death
alex's last words ah that was one hell
of a ride
marco gets a powerful fleet of ships
from his martian friends and calls it
the free navy his own personal military
of extremists to dominate the system
drummer and her crew are forced to join
marco's navy and drummer complies to
protect her family but when naomi is in
danger drummer betrays marco and attacks
his navy to save her but that gets one
of drummer's family killed and two more
of her partners leave her the terrible
cost of war is that drummer's family
grows smaller
while naomi alex and amos have their own
adventures holden faces his greatest
challenge yet spending some time alone
without his family but then marco's
belters kill fred johnson and steal a
protomolecule sample so holden and bull
and monika try to destroy it to prevent
the dangerous alien tech from falling
into the wrong hands but
they fail
marco's free navy takes control of the
ring including medina station the
all-important central hub of the ring
gates and marco lets a rogue faction of
martians through to a new world called
laconia these martians led by someone
called admiral duarte are the ones who
gave martian ships to marco and in
return marco gave them fred's
proto-molecule sample juarte is working
with a scientist cortazar to unlock the
power of the proto-molecule and to use
these mysterious alien structures
orbiting laconia to build humanity's
greatest empire but as the laconians go
through the ring one of their ships is
destroyed by these mysterious alien
entities so season 5 shatters the
balance of power earth is devastated
mars is obsolete and marco's free navy
is triumphant can the rosie crew bobby
drummer and other sorala defeat marco
and build a unified future is humanity
at threat from the alien entities in the
ring and what is going on on laconia
the final season of the expanse begins
on december 10th thanks to amazon prime
video uk for sponsoring please subscribe
to the channel for more expanse videos
soon
thanks to patrons roman solis forrest
you valerie lara malil whitetail jackson
longmire and the ultra cheese cheers
you